monsieur l'assemble bonsoir bonsoir
Monsieur Fillon plaisir de vous
accueillir ma première question est très
simple comment allez-vous monsieur la
sonde ça va très bien très occupé ces
jours-ci oui très occupé effectivement
je présume que vous voyez votre art
monté et atteindre donc les 2000 dollars
qu'est-ce qu'ils font davantagement nous
amène à 2000$ je pense qu'on va faire
beaucoup mieux que ça un peu plus long
terme sur là parce que j'ai l'impression
que moi ce qu'on vit aujourd'hui ce sont
les années
70-80 en dupliqué si vous voulez c'est
la même film mais avec différents
acteurs c'est à dire que si vous voyez
les années 70 on a eu la première hausse
de l'inflation de 1973 à 1975 on a eu
une récession qui a été très forte et
puis en 76 ça a été le début de la
grande montée vertigineuse de l'or à
partir de 90 dollars aller jusqu'à 800
dollars alors si on regarde 800 dollars
en 1980 indexé à l'inflation aujourd'hui
on parle de 3400 doll pour atteindre le
même niveau qu'on atteint dans les
années 80 alors moi c'est un peu le
scénario à auquel je regarde ouais mais
c'est le scénario auquel vous vous
attendez présentement cela dit quand je
regarde par exemple UBS là qui fait des
projections en ce moment qui nous dit
2100 dollars américains à la fin de
l'année 200200 dollars d'ici la fin de
2024 c'est une hausse beaucoup plus
modérée qui est prévue par d'autres
experts mais c'est à dire oui tout à
fait le 3400 je le vois dans un contexte
de 3 à 4 ans d'accord si vous voulez à
court terme cette année il y a encore de
grands imprévus parce que je dirais que
le prochain sommet de l'or va être dicté
par le moment où lequel le fédéral
réserve américain commence à diminuer
les taux d'intérêt alors plus ils vont
rester dans les montants qui sont
aujourd'hui moins le prix de l'or va
augmenter c'est à dire qu'on va
probablement avoir une pause et puis une
fois que on a une
qui commence le fait d'Américains ne
peuvent pas rester assez tôt là surtout
qu'il va y avoir une élection l'an
prochain aux États-Unis alors là
qu'est-ce qu'ils vont arriver ils vont
vouloir commencer à baisser les taux
parce qu'ils vont vouloir que l'économie
recommence alors ce moment-là moi je
revois une bonté assez assez bien de
quoi et pourquoi depuis trois ans à peu
près le prix de l'or s'est approché des
2000 a l'air de stagner je disais que ça
a doublé depuis 10 ans depuis 7 ans en
fait mais dans les dernières années il y
a davantage une stagnation du prix de
l'or pourquoi ben écoutez moi je pense
que c'est le 80% de la valeur de l'or à
long terme et relier au prix du dollar
américain vis-à-vis les autres devises
mondiales et avec covid avec la guerre
en Russie il y a eu si vous voulez en
Ukraine réussir
alors vous avez le monde s'est retourné
vers le dollar américain simplement
comme valeur sûre alors à ce moment-là
lors toujours recule devant la crise
réserve que le dollar américain
maintenant une fois que le dollar
américain commence à perdre de ce statut
là mais c'est là que là on fait le mieux
quoi est-ce que l'or a toujours ce
statut fondamental de valeur refuge ben
écoutez là passé les grandes banques
centrales ont acheté
1260 d'or ce qui représente un tiers de
la tour de la production mondiale de
l'or alors si vous pensez que les lors
ne représentent pas une valeur refuge
pourquoi ces grandes banques centrales
la Chine etc on aurait pas acheté dehors
pourquoi les banques centrales achètent
de l'or monsieur de la chance qu'ils ne
veulent pas avoir de dollars américains
pourquoi parce que les États-Unis ont en
effet on dit en anglais Wappen eyes le
dollar américain il y coupe il coupe les
vives tous ceux qui ont des réserves de
dollars américains simplement pour les
punir alors des sanctions partout
imposées par les Américains dans le
monde exactement alors la seule façon
pour eux d'avoir quelque chose qui
peuvent transiger rapidement bah c'est
alors parce que la valeur de l'ordre
sera transit sur une base
journalière c'est dans les milliards de
dollars
un vieil adage dit qu'un bon
investisseur doit avoir dans son
portefeuille diversifié à peu près 10 %
d'or ou de titresurifères vous êtes où
là dessus vous ben moi je dirais que en
fait ça devrait être en 5 et 10% 5 et 10
%. tout dépend des portefeuilles comment
vous gérez votre portefeuille le bon
temps de risque que vous voulez avoir
etc mais c'est entre 5 et 10% c'est le
bon chiffre quoi il y a maintenant des
crypto monnaie adossés alors qu'est-ce
que vous pensez de ça bah écoutez est-ce
que j'en suis je pense que c'est
simplement une autre façon de transiger
le fondamentalement pourquoi vous vous
auriez avoir une devise qui est en fait
qui est basé sur l'or et non pas avoir
simplement leur physique ce que vous
pouvez faire aujourd'hui vous avez
simplement acheté GLD et chaque chaque
chacun ce que vous achetez dans le
marché elle est il y a un once d'or en
arrière quelques votes de langue alors
pourquoi le faire avec des crypto
vis-à-vis le faire directement je sais
pas l'attraction de ça mais bon j'en
pensais quoi des crypto monnaie certains
considèrent parce que vous parliez de
réserve sur le dollar américain on parle
de valeur refuge sur l'or d'autres
considèrent que les crypto monnaie
peuvent reprendre représenter une forme
de refuge également qu'est-ce que vous
en pensez moi j'ai pas l'impression que
ils pourront jamais représenter d'abord
lors non seulement une valeur
fondamentale mais il faut bien se dire
que 50% de l'or est vendu en tant que
commodité pour la bijouterie pour la
danse des dentition pour l'électronique
il y a eu plus de 100 ans de panique qui
s'en va dans l'électronique votre
téléphone portable tous les trucs il y a
de l'or dedans
qui ne pourraient pas être fait sans
sans là alors il y a vraiment une valeur
nécessaire si vous voulez de l'or et en
plus il y a une valeur monétaire les
crypto c'est simplement une équation
mathématique dans l'espace
c'est de l'air c'est une équation
mathématique dans l'espace c'est ce que
vous avez alors est-ce que ça donne une
valeur refuge ça peut être multiplié
autant que vous voulez ça peut être
répliqué
moi je la vois pas
Glenn cherche à acheter la Canadienne
take resources on apprenait au début du
mois que vous envisagiez vous d'acquérir
une participation dans la nouvelle
société de charbon métallurgique que
tech prêt préparé ou tenter de séparer
parce qu'on voulait on voulait séparer
teck en deux avec du charbon d'un côté
puis des métaux de l'autre ça n'a pas
fonctionné finalement peut-être ne va
pas de l'avant avec ça et là on a
l'impression que Glenn pourrait acheter
take Resort qu'est-ce que vous pensez de
ça ce serait une tragédie pour le Canada
si cette transaction là était approuvée
par le gouvernement général parce que on
a déjà perdu au Canada nos plus grandes
compagnies minières les inko le Falcon
bridge Noranda Alkan et avec ces
disparitions aussi et toutes les emplois
qui étaient dans les bureaux chefs toute
la recherche écho vous bien se dire dans
les années 70 était à la tête de fil de
la recherche sur les batteries toutes
ces technologies est partie au Brésil
alors vous savez ce qu'on a perdu ici au
Canada en tant que propriété
intellectuelle en train de savoir-faire
c'est incroyable alors là on a une seule
compagnie qui nous reste de taille même
pas de taille géante comme ces
compagnies-là mais au moins de temps et
intermédiaire alors ce serait une
tragédie de l'avoir partir pour aller
directement aux actionnaires pour faire
sa proposition pensez-vous que les
actionnaires de tech accepteraient la
proposition Glen ils peuvent aller mais
la famille qui va encore le dernier mot
parce qu'ils ont les votes multiples la
famille qui veulent qui est le président
émérite aussi de textos exactement alors
ils ont des votes multiples et j'ai
parlé avec Norman et à aucun prix il va
vendre donc ça se voit pas non non et si
ça se faisait le gouvernement Canadien
pourrait bloquer exactement bien c'est
ce qu'on va voir Monsieur Lasson merci
d'avoir été avec nous c'est un vrai
plaisir de vous recevoir ça me fait
toujours plaisir merci pour voir nos
émissions en entier rendez-vous sur la
chaîne ici RDI